are we
alone in this universe
is there intelligent life out there
or are they living among us
humans have wondered about aliens for
centuries but
have you ever thought about the most
important
question of them all
do you think this little green man
tastes like
chicken uh i don't know if aliens
will want to make contact after seeing
this video
[Applause]
why would you want to eat an alien in
the first place would it be
unethical and
would they be safe to eat
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you ate an alien
you've embarked on a galactic journey in
search of
extraterrestrial life in the future
technology has advanced allowing us to
travel
thousands of light years away we can
finally
explore the far away planets in our
galaxy
as you reach the first planet your
stomach
crumbles in pain you've been without
food for days
the planet is barren and arid
there isn't anything around to eat
except for this guy an alien
greeting you at the entrance of your
spaceship
uh houston we have a problem
and you're going to kick our butts for
this one
there's a lot that could go wrong if a
human
noshed an alien first of all
what would an alien even taste like
some scientists say that aliens could
resemble
cephalopods here on earth namely squid
octopus and cuttlefish some theories
claim that
octopuses are aliens from outer space
[Music]
so your first encounter with an alien
might
look and taste a little more like this
anyone up for some galactic seafood
as you try to digest the alien chances
are you
probably won't be able to absorb many of
the nutrients
your body would have to be able to
process the molecules that make up the
alien
this means that the alien would have to
have a carbon-based biochemistry like
us this would be unlikely
for a life form from another planet
oh and there's another thing you'd need
to consider before chowing down
what does the alien eat be
careful if the alien hails from a planet
like mars
mars has several factors that make it
habitable for
organisms however its soil is
covered in chemicals toxic to humans
mars locals could thrive off the
chemicals as an energy source but
if you ate an alien living on a toxic
planet like mars
you could be poisoning yourself in the
process
but what if the alien was carbon-based
like us
and lived in a non-toxic environment
well you'd probably be fine eating it
but to tell you the truth i i feel a
little bad eating e.t here don't you
eating aliens could provide us with
significant nutrients
maybe even ones that we're usually
deficient in
but deciding whether or not to eat an
alien
could weigh heavily on your moral
conscience
this would especially be the case if the
alien was intelligent like
animals here on earth maybe we're better
off
looking for some plants somewhere else
on the planet
but what if instead of journeying
in search of aliens they have
already found us what if they're
watching us
right now well in that case
hello aliens we come in peace forget
about everything i said before
we totally wouldn't eat you
okay now hopefully i don't get beamed up
by aliens and
i'll still be here for another
what if